two measures and then the next most
relevant predictor is the trait
conscientiousness which is not a trait
we understand at all we have no measures
of conscientiousness that work we've got
a couple of weak ones but no measures
that really work better than self-report
and other reports could be meticulous be
a good way to explain conscientiousness
meticulousness is associated with
orderliness and orderliness is one of
the aspects of conscientiousness but
conscientious people the best way to sum
up a conscientious person is that
they're very good at keeping contracts
with themselves and others so what a
conscientious person will do is first of
all say that they'll do some things so
that's the first thing but then they'll
actually do it so they seem to be able
to and they seem to be the crucial they
yeah but it's crucial if it's especially
crucial if you're a manager and
administrator it's not so crucial if
you're an entrepreneur if you want to
hold yourself to achieving goals yeah
yeah well they tend to be who want to
work your way up the competence
hierarchy probably a good way to do that
is to say I'm going to do something and
do